let's first what start out by finding
out what's your sin is Santa's secret
secrets he doesn't want us to know it's
Santee here anywhere let's look for
Santa let's look around maybe he's here
somewhere
let's see if we can't find say hey up
there right up there there he is that's
there's Santa
no no say hey hey don't go away hey
Santa Claus hey there how's it going
codin know as Santa is there anything
that you'd like to share with us nope
bye-bye no no no Santa Santa come on you
came all the way here I'm sure there's
something okay there is one thing but
it's kind of embarrassing come closer
yeah well see ya sometimes I give cold
to the good kids too
I just like messing with nerds hey so
now they want tomatoes and every year I
skip over Marissa Tomei house because
she once snubbed me for an autograph
Santa's pity okay sort of surprising
revelations oh yeah
Conan one more thing yeah I eat hot dogs
the same way most people eat corn on the
cob it's pretty weird right yeah that's
disturbing actually
but yeah visit your homes on Easter and
Thanksgiving too just to look around you
could go anywhere when you're white know
why you want to know why I fly around in
a sleigh 14 DUIs is drunk driving yeah
okay
also Peter made me stop using reindeers
so now my sleigh is pulled by eight Wall
Street bankers who liked it in which we
get it Thank You Santa we should go and
what I'm flying around when I'm flying
around I have plenty of time to listen
to podcasts and yet I don't listen to
yours
to meeting alright well maybe that's a
little little low blow you should've
kept back to yourself
hey-ya hey-ya what sometimes I leave
gifts for Jewish kids with a note that
says look what you're missing
[Applause]
to children all over the world I'm known
as Santa Claus but on pornhub I go by
chimney stuffers 69
[Applause]